Oh what is going home you two always
with the hands now as you get older
marriage is going to come up in the
topic of your conversations more and
more often people get all the pinyon
business asking so when you go get very
you still ain't mad again you like boys
or something
look what [ __ ] why you know it at your
home you start to get married you start
to wonder if you should hurry up and
trick a woman into marriage but along
these lines I was having a conversation
with my friend about engagement rings
that fascinated me she and a couple of
her other friends were telling me the
minimum amount that they want their man
to spend on their engagement ring and
the tip about dick nearly exploded so
let's go ahead and talk about this you
already know what this LGI baby let's
get it let's go why the hell do we have
to spend so much money on a goddamn ring
and a few you ladies out there I don't
know what you're saying
because you love her she's worth it it's
not about the money it's not about the
money [ __ ] of course it's not ain't
your money look I don't have a problem
with the symbolism of a marriage or an
engagement ring I think it's beautiful
problem is why should the importance of
my love for you be based on an object
that doesn't do [ __ ] I heard from a few
girls that a minimum that Richard cost
is thirty to forty thousand dollars but
thirty thousand owes you must be out
your goddamn mind do you have any idea
what we as a couple could do with thirty
thousand dollars we can get a car but
money down a house start a college fund
have a tiger trained to scratch my balls
say gently every night yeah that's right
I looked it up you can have it happen
yeah not as expensive as you think
either I got dreams let me ask you
something what's that diamond really do
for you our one girl say to me give me
good if times get rough we could sell it
if we ever need them money
number one what are you preparing
yourself with a Great Depression calm
your ass down
Co you know what else we can do to have
thirty thousand dollars in our base not
spend $30,000 and here
no matter how much money we make what
makes you think that we all live like
the Kardashians [ __ ] you should have
chose her first day and described our
lifestyle keeping up with the Kim's a
Korean reality show would be the dumbest
[ __ ] offer you know why because that
[ __ ] would get too real daddy I think
I'm pregnant
okay well daddy have to kill you now you
know what can I ask you something what
you gonna get me that for $30,000
I believe in women empowerment and
equality so what you got and please
don't say [ __ ] like the gift of light
and gonna bear your child one day [ __ ]
that is not a gift that's a financial
burden you you basically told me to buy
you a rock in a million dollar baby
selfish and don't even say sex not touch
my goddamn self with that type of money
hashtag truth I can't believe you said
bear me a child with your biblical after
mile [ __ ] a 21st century Thrones you
you know I've slowly begun to realize
that there are a lot of people out there
that love to base their relationships on
these stupid inanimate objects that give
them a fake sense of appreciation and
love and you know what let's just be
real for a moment there's a handful of
girls out there they want a fat ring on
their fingers just so they could go to
their girls and be like oh my god my
fingers feel so heavy oh my god Jenny
why I don't know maybe is because of
this woman you think my future wife I am
definitely gonna get for a beautiful
ring but that's not the problem why
should your partner tell you how to go
about and how much you should spend on
their ring that she doesn't make sense
to me in a relationship if you think
looking at that rock is gonna help you
through your tough times you are sadly
mistaken and you would think you've
learned because didn't you see what
happened to Kobe bender meant by his
wife of a jillion dollar ring and she
still left him took the ring and took
his money and balzac with him hey you
know what they say the bigger the rough
the more people ask well what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] do
Oh what oh god I must drop my [ __ ] topic
of engagement rings that in fasten it in
fascinated and don't even met us not
even a [ __ ] word dog God dead read a
book read a book [ __ ] she and a couple
of other girl autumn with the symbolism
and the bubble of the tan but murder and
again fake a lot of people out there
they like to have that idea ninja